[موسيقى]
الشخص العادي يفكر في اليوم 60 الف
فكره متخيلين ايش يعني 60 ال
فكره يعني زيه زي الكمبيوتر حتى ممكن يكون
اكبر من
كمبيوتر بس على كده اللي
بيصير انه في
75% من الافكار مكرره بمعنى لو انك فكرتي
في وقت معين عدد من الافكار حيكون ثلاث
ارباعها مكرر ايش اكلتي فين
حتروحي مع مين ح تخرجي ايش حتقولي هذه
كلها لها مكرره وهذا الشيء اللي
يبرر المشكله الاكبر اللي عندنا في مصطلح
انجليزي يقولوا ذا الفنت ان روم يستخدم
هذا
المصطلح لما تكون في مشكله كبيره زي الفيل
موجود في الغرفه لكن احنا ما احنا شايفينه
وبنحلم مشاكل الصغيره في ناس كثير تيجي
تقول انا ما اعرف ايش ابغى ما اعرف ما
عندي حلم ما عندي اهتمامات ما عندي هوايات
ماني موهوبه في حاجه واللي تسويه انه هم
يروحوا لدورات كيف تحقق حلمك كيف توصل
للحلم حقك وهم اصلا ما عندهم حلم هذا
الفيل الاول اللي هو المشكله الكبيره اللي
هو ما عندهم حلم ما في
اهتمام لكن في فيل اكبر من هذا وفي مشكله
اكبر من هذه اللي هو انهم ما عملوا حاجه
عشان يوصلوا لهذا الحلم او عشان يوصلوا
لهذا
الاهتمام وهذا الفيل الاكبر والمشكله
الاكبر من اكثر الناس اللي انا احبهم من
وان صغيره ليوناردو
ديفانشي ليش عشان وانا صغيره كنت من اكثر
الناس اللي يحبوا يسووا اشياء كثيره عمري
ما كنت من الناس اللي يسووا شيء واحد
وليوناردو ديفانشي كان نفس الشيء ليوناردو
ديفانشي يمكن اغلبكم يعرفوه عشان هو رسم
ال الموناليزا لكن هذه هي خريطه ليوناردو
ديفانشي ليوناردو كان رسام كان نحات كان
مهندس كان عالم خرايط كان كان جيولوجي كان
يسوي 500
شيء هذه الخريطه حق ليوناردو الاشياء اللي
جربها طلعت خريطه اكبر وخريطه اهم اللي هي
الاشياء اللي تعلمها من كل شيء جربه اتعلم
الصبر اتعلم الدقه اعلم الاهتمام
بالتفاصيل
من من هذه الاشياء ليوناردو ديفانشي قدر
يرسم الموناليزا طيب ايش بتقولي اللي انا
بقوله مو صعب مو لازم احد يكون لوناردو
ديفانشي عشان يوصل للحل الاطفال هم اول من
لقوا حل للمشاكل حقتنا اللي دحين لو
تشوفوا لو عندكم في البيت طفل او احد قريب
عندكم عنده طفل تلاقي انه الطفل بيلعب بكل
حاجه ابتداء من اغراض البيت للاشياء اللي
الاقيها مرميه ل شبابيك للالعاب بعد كذا
يبدا يقول لا انا ابغى طياره انا ابغى
باربي انا ابغى سياره يصير عنده اهتمام
محدد الحل ما حتعرفي انت ايش تحبي لو ما
جربتي التجربه هي الحل هذا الشيء اللي
احنا ما
بنسويه هذا الشيء حاولت اتعلم منه وفي شيء
جدا الهمني اللي هو في كتاب
اسمه هو كتاب هو كده لسته اشياء 101 حاجه
تقوللك ايش الاشياء اشياء غبيه حقيقي
اشياء غبيه عمرنا ما نفكر نسويها في اليوم
ليش عشان ما عندنا وقت عشان هي ما هي في
جدول حياتنا عشان عندنا اشياء اهم هذا
باعتقادنا انه عندنا اشياء اهم من اننا
نتعلم ونجرب ونعرف ايش بنسوي اشتريت
الكتاب ده وبدات اسوي الاشياء اللي فيه
الاشياء اللي في ما تتخيلوا ش هي يعني
مثلا جيبي قاروره واكتبي فيها رساله
وقفلها وارميها في الب
عشان شخص في الشاطئ الثاني يلاقيها وتكون
هذه الرساله لي مين في يومه ممكن يفكر
يسوي شي زي
كذا في
احد
جربيها الشيء ال 101 بعد ما تخلص 100 شيء
الشي 101 يقوللك استمتعي بالحياه لانه
عمرك ما حتعرفي ايش في الحياه لو ما
جربتي من بعد هذه الاشياء بدات اجرب اسوي
اسوي اشياء كثيره وعدد مرات الفشل تجاوز
بكثير عدد المرات اللي نجحت
فيها لكن كل واحد من الاشياء اللي جربتها
وفشلت فيها علمني عشان في النهايه قدرت
اكتب بعد
الحلم افتكر اول ما بدات ميزان لما دخلت
ميزان وصرت ماسكه المحتوى العربي وبدانا
نكتب عن رياضات من ه الجري السباحه الى
اخره طب انا ما يعني ما امارس هذه
الرياضات فقلت لا لازم اجرب في اكثر من
400 رياضه الناس اللي مثلا تقول انا ما
احب الرياضه كيف ما تحب الرياضه في 400
رياضه في احد جرب 400 رياضه كلها فلما
بدانا نكتب على الموقع عن عن الرياضات
بدات اجرب جربت
الجري عرفت انه انا عمري في حياتي ما ح
اكون عداءه مو الشي اللي انا احبه لكن
تعلمت انه بعد الجري بعد مده معينه من
الجري الشخص يدخل في حاله ذهنيه
معينه هذه الحاله الذهنيه ساعدتني اني
اكتب يعني انا كنت بجري عشان اعرف
اكتب فسار الجري بيساعدني مو
العكس مو الكتابه اللي بتساعدني عشان اجري
مو الكتابه اللي بتحفز ني عشان اجري الجري
هو اللي حفزني على الكتابه وبعدها لمما
سار اهتمام الكتابه لقيت انه كل تجربه انا
سويتها في حياتي كانت تصب خبرتها وتساعدني
على
الكتابه مراحل
التجربه
افتكر لما وقفت على على مسرح الفكر العربي
لما صرت سفير الفكر العربي عمري ما افتكرت
عدد المرات اللي انا نجحت فيها ما كنت
بفكر كذا لحظات نجاح كنت بفكر اكثر في
لحظات الفشل ليش لانه اكبر الخبرات اللي
صارت عندي التجارب صارت عندي من الفشل
فصرت بفكر كيف يصير طالما انه الفرصه
متاحه لكل شخص انه يجرب ليش في ناس ما
تجرب كم مره جت في بالك فكره ونسيتيه ما
سويتيها بعدها بسنه ولا بعدها بفتره لقيتي
احد ثاني عامل هذه الفكره وهذه الفكره
ناجحه في احد صار معه الشي
ده
واحد اثنين
ثلاثه
اربعه كثير طيب ايش اللي يفرق كيف انت جت
في بالك فكره وما سويتيها وفي احد ثاني جت
في بالي الفكره نفسها وسواها التجربه
مراحل اول مرحله الخوف اول ما تبدا عند
الواحد فكره يخاف انه يسويها وهذا طبيعي
عشان هذا الخوف من المجهول بعد كذا يتحمس
بعد كده يجيله احباط لو انه حاول في
البدايه ولقى عقبات بعدها اذا استمر ممكن
ينجح وممكن تصير عنده خبره ما ح اقول عنها
فشل في شيئين في هذ في هذا السلايد اول
شيء انه الناس غالبا توقف في مرحلتين يا
اما توقف في البدايه مرحله الخوف الفكره
اللي جات وما حاولت اصلا تسويها او في
مرحله
الاحباط الشيء الثاني انه التجربه بعد ما
تجربي حاجه وتوصلي لنهايتها اللي يصير انه
تكون هذه نهايه التجربه هي بدايه لتجربه
جديده تنفتح لك بس في حال انك جربتي لكن
اذا انت اصلا ما بداتي فعمرك ما حتوصل
للتجربه
الثانيه طيب هل لازم تجربي كل شيء في
العالم في مقوله برضه ليوناردو ديفانشي
كان
بيقولها مقوله حقت ليوناردو ديفانشي انه
الطبيعه كانت طيبه كفايه لدرجه انه انت كل
ما تديري وجهك في الطبيعه حتتعلم حتلاقي
المعرفه اللي بيقولوا هو باختصار انه
حياتنا بالطريق اللي احنا بعاملها بنصحى
نروح الدوام نقابل ناس نرجع ننام نصحى
ثاني يوم الحياه الروتينيه هذه عمرها في
حياتها ما حتديكي
مكان الكون هو اكبر حقل
تجارب الكون كله عباره عن حقل تجارب تقدري
تستخدميه بالطريقه اللي تبغيها في الوقت
اللي تبغيه تسوي فيها اللي تبغيه طيب ايش
اجرب مين يفتكر كان يسوي شيء زمان كانت
تحب الرسم كانت تكتب كانت تنحت كانت تسوي
اي حاجه وبطلت مع الانشغالات
ابداي من ذاك المكان هذاك المكان ممكن ما
يكون المكان اللي تنتهي به لكن هو المكان
اللي حتبدا
فيه بعدها ممكن تكتشفي انه انت مره رسامه
فنانه بعدها او تكتشفي لا انه انت ما انت
رسامه انت شيء ثاني لكن هذا المكان اللي
تبداي منه اذا ما عندك ولا حاجه ابدا بشيء
جديد ما انت خسرانه
صوري لما تبدا بتجربه ح تكتشفي التجربه
اللي بعدها واللي بعدها والي بعدها ما
تعرفي ايش مفروض
تكوني اكبر العقبات اللي صارت عند الناس
لما طالبه يقوللها ركزي في دراستك يا شيخه
مالك الكلام الفاضي ده لا تضيعي على نفسك
ركزي ولا تكون في شغل تقوللك لا يا شيخ ما
عندي وقت كلام فاضي الرسول صلى الله عليه
وسلم يقول ان لله في ايام الدهر نفحات
فتعرضوا لها فلعل احدكم ان تصيبه نفحه ف
يشقى بعدها ابدا حطي نفسك دائما في وجه
المدفع جربي ممكن تفشلي 1000 مره المره
الف واحد ممكن تكون هي مره النجاح ممكن
تكون هي النفحه اللي لكي فما اعرف الكلام
اللي الناس يقولوه لنا ولا كلام الرسول
صلى الله عليه
وسلم لازم تنجح في كل تجربه
لا هل يفرق عدد المرات اللي فشلت فيها
برضه لا كم مره تحتاجي تنجحي مره واحده
بدليل ليوناردو ديفانشي لم وتكم
الموناليزا مين يعرف لوناردو ديفينشي فشل
كم مره ما اعتقد احد يعرف لكن هل هو مهم
ان نعرف لوناردو ديفينشي فشل كم مره لا
لانه في النهايه رسم الموناليزا اي تحفه
موجوده في العالم اي رسمه اي اختراع بشري
كان نتيجه نجاح مره واحده مقابل عدد مرات
من الفشل غير مهم
اخر سلايد عندي انه التجربه لو حاولت
تجربي اي حاجه حيكون نتيجتها واحد من ثلاث
اشياء يا اما ح تنجحي فيها يا اما ح تفشلي
وبالتالي يصير عندك خبره تستفيدي منها في
التجربه اللي بعدها او
حتندمي لكن لو ما جربتي وقعدت طول حياتك
عندك اشياء بتفكري فيها لكن عمرك ما
جربتيها حيصير حاجه واحده بس حتفضلي تفكري
ايش حيصير لو جربتها نتيجه عدم التجربه هو
شيء واحد فقط هو
[موسيقى]
الندم
ه